Now we're going to explore these
ideas in a thought experiment
called the coin flipping casino.
So, instead of buying and selling
stocks, we're going to flip coins and
we're going to be on the outcome of
whether those coins come up heads or
tails.
So that's analogous to a single
investment in a stock, or
a single trade in a stock,
where you buy it and hold it and
either you make money or you lose money.
Well, we're going to flip a coin and
either make money or lose money.
Now the coin is biased.
In other words,
we have information about this coin, and
we know that it's more likely
to come up heads than tails.
In fact, that probability is about
0.51 that it will come up heads.
So that's our edge, that's like our
alpha when investing in stocks.
And the uncertainty of the outcome
is like beta in stock investing.
Here's how betting works.
So you can bet on any particular
coin flip, you can bet n coins.
If you win,
in other words it comes up heads.
You now have 2 n coins.
If you lose they take your money.
So this is called an even money bet.
So on each outcome you either
make n coins or you lose n coins.
Here's how the casino works.
There are 1,000 betting tables
each with their own biased coin,
and you have 1,000 tokens.
So you can chose to
bet however you like.
In other words, you can put ten tokens
on each of a hundred tables, you could
put a thousand tokens on one table, you
could put one token on all the tables.
Once you've distributed all your tokens,
which represent your bets,
the coins are all flipped at once.
In other words the game runs in
parallel, and for each bet that
you made you either Get your winnings or
they take the chips that you bet.
So now that we've set up this
environment for us to experiment with,
I want you to think
a little bit about it and
think about how would you
allocate these tokens?
Is it better to bet all your
tokens on just one coin flip, or
is it better to bet on
multiple coin flips at once?